what is it can we eat it
it's skin is so translucent like a sea
jelly
I shall poke it let us all poke it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
go with clear up Aquaman plus Wolverine
the mash-up is sushi deluxe yeah
Aquaman plus flash flush that would be
flush yeah
kitty pryde plus Deadpool that would be
kiddy pool oh I guess the best way that
I can describe it imagine like like
training day right like the energy of
training day David Rohde training day
right yep so yeah pretty good energy of
training day so got it so it's like the
energy of training day meets
Lord of the Rings got it right yeah yeah
so like imagine like Lord of the Rings
was like 4,000 years ago yeah but then
the creatures came forward into present
day and now we're in gritty grimy
present-day Los Angeles right but
there's orcs and stuff running over
right even m/l who plays Green Arrow and
this is a show this is a show i watch
with this is a show i watch with my
children and so I know this show well he
has said that he would like to do a
crossover on to your show is that
something that certainly is that
something you would want I'm not sure I
have a show I don't want just random
people crossing over into my show I have
standards
I want a group it's like a private club
I want to lift a rope let's some in and
then like I'm not sure you know let the
green arrow in flash I'm not sure you
know how is it with you guys II odd
tonight on Law & Order arrow
[Laughter]
[Music]
you